my dad said he wouldn't give me a job so
i i had to show him
right right so i got a job and i
coordinated um
an afi movie that was a 250 thousand
dollar grant
um and then one did a couple of movies
for usher armorage who then went on to
become pretty big producer
yeah but in the days that he was doing
small indies so yeah
been around for a while wow and so did
you ever go
and get your degree or you you no you
know i always
i kept working i went to i want to go
back to um
to study i went back to ucla um
because i kept you know i started i
started writing and i thought god i'm
a big fat liar right i don't really know
what i'm doing
so i went and took a class
and i still felt like i didn't know what
i was doing but then at the end
of the semester the professor asked me
to come and be his ta
and i kind of went okay if i'm lying to
you and pulling it off i don't need to
be here
i need to be either with somebody who
calls me on my lie that i don't know
what i'm doing
um or just keep writing so i just kept
on writing and everybody that i talked
about a lot of friends at that point
who were in grad school for film um
who said listen if if you're not
planning to direct which i never was
um you know your best experience is on
the ground
you know read a lot of scripts talk to a
lot of people um you know go learn how
to make movies
um rather than have this fantastical
ideas of what it is so i went and
you know kept kept working in production
wrote a script
um was lucky enough to get an option
then sold
had a big agency packaging it and
finally found out i didn't want to be a
writer which i consider the greatest
gift of my life
um well you had said that you enjoyed
giving notes but it was
tougher to receive them i was i i think
it had to do with youth
i think i also had to do with my idea of
the process
from the writer's side that didn't mesh
up with reality
i like developing material i have a
problem especially in the 90s you know
which was a time where
anybody could be a development executive
and so you had development executives
that weren't necessarily
qualified um who would give you notes
about a movie in small town america
going well maybe we can do this in
mexico can it be a mexican family
because i've always wanted to go to
mexico on vacation so maybe you could go
live there for a few months and you just
go
wow what am i supposed to do with that
um
you know so it was i didn't enjoy it i
didn't enjoy
creativity by consensus a lot of my
writers love it
and i can certainly help them navigate
through it
for me it wasn't the thing i would much
rather develop material and work with
writers
than be the writer to me that was just a
miserable experience doesn't mean it's
miserable for anybody else
but for me it just wasn't a fit so i was
lucky enough to know enough people to
be able to quickly make the transition
into development and start developing
material
do you think that because you didn't
have the pressure of student loans that
a lot of people that come here and i'm
talking
i also left at 17 and don't have a
degree and so i have a similar
background in that sense and you don't
have the pressure of student loans and
having to pay those off that you're able
to do
stuff that's a little more creative and
free um
yeah but i also you know i was i was
independent
at a very early age so for me it was
rent for me it was self-sustaining i
didn't you know
my parents were very much about we want
you to stand on your own two feet which
was fantastic
um i think it gave me freedom but i also
honestly i very rarely
see people make choices specifically
because of their student loans
um i wish they they made more choices
that were that would directly influence
that
um you know but my experience was with
film was always you know you can
study film appreciation you need to see
all the classics and i've taken those
classes over the years
you know ad nauseam but for me
film and film making is a very practical
experience
so being on the ground that was why i
did it it wasn't you know i didn't want
to take on the student loan or
or any of those things it just really
wasn't something that attracted me i
kind of felt like
why stop this train right of going out
there and making movies and being in the
industry and making contacts
and being part of it to go be in school
in a make-believe world
let's pretend that we're going to write
something that's going to end up on the
screen
most films most screenplays that are
written in academia never see the light
of days
most movies that are you never make a
feature
in college i made features all the time
i mean i i
pretty i was production coordinator
production manager on them but that was
the world that i live in so
for me it always felt like if i'm
already in it
and i can take these classes between
shoots and at night and go to film
appreciation film history and
study goddard and fellini and and you
know all of those great filmmakers
and understand shot composition and
directing rules and all of those things
why do i need to stop why do i need to
stop and go back to college for four
years it see
it felt to me then like a step back of
course it's great to have a degree
but i don't find that in filmmaking
specifically for writers
a degree in screenwriting is what
makes a career i actually feel that film
school is a lot more important for
directors
because you get that short you get those
connections you get you get to be you
know the top short at eoc or at ucla
or at columbia college or you know nyu
it really is a place for a director to
kind of cut his teeth and
and get a quality short together
then again and i will argue that side
because i'm a gemini so that duality is
always warring
um in this day and age with the access
to digital filmmaking you can make a
great short anywhere
um but i do think the directors need
more incubating and considering
how to storyboard something why do you
storyboard it that way what are the
choices that you're making in director
what is the color composition of a shot
all of those things i think that falls
into play a lot more in film school than
than writing uh for writers i think that
i used to make a
greater impact going to going through
film school with a focus on
screenwriting than it does today
lee and your bio you say that the
writers that you've seen
make it or have success often know
their strengths and weaknesses they're
very self-aware
that's great but who do they actually
trust to tell them the truth about that
because so many people will say oh
you're so wonderful but there's like a
hidden agenda
and then there's vice versa they're sort
of the poisonous playmates
as well of course you have to find the
people that you trust i mean listen the
reality is that
this is a two-sided coin on one side
nobody likes confrontation
nobody wants to be the bad friend that
told you that you know
you stink you sweat too much um so
change like nobody wants to have those
conversation about
what doesn't work because they want to
be your friends and they want to have
wine with you and they want to kick back
and they don't want the weight of they
said something uncomfortable to you
on the other end you have the people who
are not at your level who just want to
kind of hang on and see where you're
going and everything you do is great and
brilliant fantastic
um it really is a honcho really is about
finding the people that you trust
to tell you the good and bad um i
generally don't and this is me and this
is
not politically correct i find that
you can be on the side of the rider on
the side of the sale at the same time
um which is why i work the way that i
work because if i'm invested in
selling something my first priority
stops being the writer
and it starts being putting money in my
bank right
so i think that you have to find people
who are
whose job is to be honest with you um
it used to be managers that were a lot
more hands-on with creative development
career development
but because the business model changed
so aggressively in 2008 after the 2008
strike
very few still have that luxury you know
managers used to have a small roster 15
20 people
now we're seeing i see many of my
friends in management
who used to have small rosters suddenly
with 30 40 50 clients because now it
takes twice the time to break
a writer or sell a script for half the
money so you have to load your roster if
you want to keep making the same money
that you did
so you have to find people who are not
invested and necessarily
in making money off of you but are
invested in your long-term best interest
who will be honest with you who will not
be who are not competing with you
competition element is always tough
because the moment you have competition
there inevitably and subconsciously
other emotions that come into play that
may taint
why someone is saying something so you
really do have to find your team
that you can always go back to i had a
writer
years ago who wrote a script that had a
lot of heat on it
and he was signed by caa and i kept
telling him you have to get a manager
you have to get somebody who's on your
side who'll give it to you straight
i wasn't coaching at that time yet um
but you know he came to me through
script shark um which i was running for
six and a half years
we became quite friendly i gave him some
advice my advice was find somebody on
your side
not on the side of selling the script
um ultimately the script fizzled out and
he fizzled out
in such a drastic and dramatic
fashion he made such mistakes
that nobody at the big agency that
signed him
was going to stop and train him on it or
talk him through it or consider the
option
or say don't you ever freaking say that
um you know he was effectively put on
stage to perform didn't know how to
perform
thought that he did which was a huge
mistake um and so everything fizzled if
he had somebody in his
ear who was coaching him who was
training him who knew what the hell they
were talking about
that mistake wouldn't have happened but
he was you know his his movie that or
his screenplay that
was very much the talk of the town
disappeared overnight
he fizzled um and was dropped by the
agency from one day
to the next based on very simple
mistakes that the writer made
that had he had somebody invested in him
and not in just
the money would have been different
how does a writer become more self-aware
if they don't have representation they
don't have anybody yet in their camp
they're new but they want to learn
what mistakes are they making is from
something as simple as even going in to
pitch something
and how they're presenting themselves
well the thing is uh first of all
there's there's the script element right
so
you want to expose the work early and
often to people that you can trust or
that there is no
no negative impact if they don't like
the work so readers consultants
you want to get feedback from people in
the know writers groups other writers
that you respect
um your mother your best friend your
husband your wife your kid
love them they don't count unless they
are you know
kelly masterson who just wrote snow
piercer sure if you're if you're
married to kelly masterson go get his
two cents and
by all means but short of that you want
to find on the script front first of all
you want to find people
that will give you script feedback that
is knowledgeable and seasoned
so it's not it can't be just anybody i
don't like
notes from anonymous sources because if
i don't know who's giving the notes how
do i know to trust the notes
um you know and then when it comes to
things like this like story expo pitch
events
you want to walk in prepped i can tell
you that for example for me i do preps
with my writers i did
i did eight sessions of prep with one
writer for one event
going over the pitch going over the one
sheet making sure that it's coming off
the right way
making sure i'm getting no distractions
that same writer went to writer friends
to
writers who are sho show runners who
become showrunners
writers who are writing in rooms and ran
the pitch by them to really prepare and
practice
there are a lot of people that walk into
pitch event and think oh i can just wing
it the reality is that in today's world
there's enough
resources out there to not have to wing
it you can walk in prepared so whether
you work with somebody like me or
somebody like stephanie palmer
who works on pitching or you know read
michael hey
selling your script in 60 seconds you
have some starting points to really
start planning and preparing because
ultimately luck favors the prepared
lee what's the first step in writing a
screenplay
first step in writing a screenplay is
making sure that you have a really solid
great idea
without that killer idea it doesn't
matter how technically sound the script
is
it's just not going to resonate so you
have to make sure
that the idea which is the foundation of
the script
is solid is interesting it's different
is exciting um a friend of mine dwayne
alexander
wrote a book a few years ago
dwayne smith keep calling him by his
life by his middle name
dwayne alexander smith uh dwayne smith
wrote a book
uh 10 simple rule rules for
writing a great screenplay
um and nine of his rules were somewhat
technical
and one rule was the big idea and what
he said in that book was listen i can
teach you those nine other rules
but if you don't follow the tenth the
big idea
rule you're not going to have a script
because it really is about and you see
this in the pitch rooms you see this you
know we're now
in an event where people are walking in
pitching work that they started six
months ago or a year ago or
a year and a half or two years ago
whatever it is they're walking and
they're pitching if they don't have that
big idea to sell
nobody's reading the work because it is
about that big idea it is about that
unique character that we haven't seen
before it's about that
world that we haven't been in it's about
a conflict that's unique and different
now it can always
been argued there are eight great themes
they've all been done and redone
fantastic but we're still finding new
ways to tell
to tell great movies um take for example
things like
i don't know why i keep going back to
kelly masterson but before the devil
knows you're dead
amazing story shakespearean quality
fantastic script totally different
amazing
look at movies like run lola run look at
movies that are as simple as boyhood
it's a different way to tell a story and
what we want to see from a writer is
what is your unique point of view what
is your unique story
so for me the the first and most
important step
is picking that idea that has real legs
whether it's for a screenplay or for a
television pilot
what is unique about what's different
about it what's the same about it so
that i can understand where it fits in
it's not too radical we're not
creating whole new worlds but there is
something here that is interesting to me
that i haven't
seen in this form before
first it's that then it's starting to
outline to really beat out an idea and
see does it hold
you really have to do those preparatory
steps before you jump
into the script because it's much easier
figuring out an outline if it doesn't
work
then figuring out three drafts you know
500 pages and two years later
that you just can't make it work so you
do have to go through those steps you do
have to fix the work
you do have to make sure that it holds
that it has enough promise
screenwriting is ultimately an iterative
process
nobody gets it right the first time
you're not supposed to there's a reason
why they call the first draft the vomit
draft
um so you have to go through those
iterations once you have that id you
have to
to give it the right treatment in order
to get it to a place where it can be a
solid
promising full of potential piece of
work
that has some real legs if you were
going to arm a screenwriter with one
tool or weapon what would it be
i'm assuming we're we're talking uh
weapons for screening of writing yeah
i'm not walking down the street yeah oh
gosh that is a really good question
um writing-wise it will always be the
ability to outline
that to me is is one of those tools
that are completely underrated that are
rarely taught
but are integral because i can tell you
all of my clients who are represented
before they go to script it's always
show me the outline
and this is not something they're
traditionally taught so for me the
the ability to outline cohesively um
in five pages 10 pages 18 pages
that is the tool that to me is just
underrated
and absolutely crucial so far as
industry tools
i would like to grant them more
confidence less bravado
more confidence so the ability to walk
in
comfortably and start building
relationships because truly
this is a business of relationships and
you know certainly i want all my writers
to be able to pitch well whatnot but it
starts with
a certain level of believing in the
value of the work
um truly understanding it and being able
to parlay that in a room
so that is an incredibly important tool
for me the ability to walk into a room
to start to network to make some
relationships
can you give me an example of bravado
versus real confidence
um bravado versus real confidence is
quite simple
this is the greatest script ever oh my
god it's gonna make
500 million dollars domestically because
it's the greatest thing that was ever
written
that's bravado it's completely baseless
um it doesn't speak to anything
other than the writer's fantasy
confidence
speaks to the ability of a writer to sit
down and say i want to talk to you about
something that i wrote
that i'm really excited about i wrote it
inspired by my relationship with my
father
who was a forensic psychologist who also
happened to abuse
his mother and children this is somebody
who can just sit down and talk about the
work and there's difference i think i
feel that a lot of writers make a lot of
empty promises
about the work um and and i see it in
pictures all the time i mean i went over
a pitch with
with a team of writers a few days ago
who said oh this is just the greatest
conspiracy ever in the history of
america why
what happened what the hell are you
talking about
talk to me about what it is rather than
what you want it to be or how powerful
you want me to see it as
i find that writers who are confident in
the work who have done the work and it's
only writers who've done the work
who've who've gotten notes who've gotten
the feedback they can walk in truly
confident
they can walk in and just talk to you
about the work they don't need to
do an interpretive dance to go along
with it they don't need to promise you
that it'll make millions of dollars or
that
you know americans will tune in every
friday night in droves to see the show
they know what the work is so it's the
confidence to be able to sit down
talk about the work as a professional to
another professional
on the other side of the table advice to
a screenwriter
working on their first screenplay and
thinking they're going to sell it
move to malibu we had another guy in
this chair that would always use the
word malibu as like
you know sell it malibu money comes
but that that notion that that first
screenplay is going to be it for them
and watch them
for the first bit of advice that i have
is you're not going to sell it
a first script is a learning script um
i was i was teaching class yesterday and
and i told the writers if you're
pitching a script that is your first
script
don't ever say this is my first script
because the minute that we hear people
like me here this is my first script we
know this is your learning script
you're gonna learn how to write on your
first second third script
by the fourth script you're gonna get
kinda good by the fifth script you'll
really have a handle on your voice
so there is no selling that first script
i literally don't know
anybody literally who sold
their first script in recent years i
mean granted last night i interviewed
uh scott alexander and larry kurzowski
who wrote um ed wood
larry flint man of the moon and they did
manage to sell their first script
but this was in 1980 something
um and they and they said in the room
this is clearly not the way
that it's done um so in all likelihood
odds are you're not going to sell your
first you got to love it you got to put
your heart into it
but you have to understand this is an
intellectual exercise and learning how
to write screenplays
you really do have to see it as your
training piece
so if you have five ideas and one you
love and it's the one that you think is
going to make you a million dollars
hold that back work on your skill before
you invested in it because oftentimes
i'll talk to my writers who are
newer writers and we'll talk about where
script is at and they will say to me i
think i brought it as far as i can bring
it
skill wise at this point i need to set
it aside
if i wanted to go further i need to
revisit it in a year two years when i've
worked on other stuff
which is the right the right assumption
what a writer should expect is that it's
going to take three to ten years to
break into the entertainment industry
that's what it takes this is what we see
day in and day out
it is hardly ever done in shorter spurts
i know somebody watching this will go
well i'm the one who's going to do it
and more power to you but
this is just the general expectations i
have both clients and friends who are
breaking in all the time
every day they're all working at it for
years and
that's okay this is what it takes this
is how it works
in all likelihood you are not selling
your first if your first can get you
some exposure
fantastic but we are in an industry
where right now we're in the beginning
of september we sold 43 specs
this year that's an abysmal number so
we're not selling a lot of product right
now it's going to change we're going to
sell more
but the likelihood of selling a script
in a market where roughly 80
000 scripts are getting registered a
year with the wga
and 41 or 43 are selling within
eight nine months not high you just have
to run the numbers
it is a lottery so save that passion
project
because i've heard a lot of people here
today that want to write about something
that happened to them when they were
younger whatever
and they're very close to the material
maybe that one that they think is going
to
to change everything that's very
personal to them hold back on that
you're saying
work on five or six others that maybe
aren't as
perfect your script you become a better
writer this is a skill based craft your
skill gets stronger and stronger and
muscle gets stronger and stronger
the more you write so you do have to
keep writing and perfecting your craft
in order to get to a place where you can
write those really hard to execute
scripts
the screenwriting process the first week
of the screenplay
versus the last week how different how
challenging
um listen the first week is all promise
right it's all hope and promise of what
this thing will become
the last week is often exhaustion
some feeling of triumph some feeling of
disappointment
the movie on in the head as opposed to
the movie
on the page should be a successful
moment you know for me
a writer who keeps writing on the work
should keep writing on the work to get
to a point where it's inspiring where
it's exciting where they're happy with
it
um so there should be some feeling of
relief usually the week
after the last week of the script is the
week of mourning
you no longer have those characters
waiting for you
um you're on to the next thing you're
starting something that is
very raw very rough so
it definitely goes through a real arc
the writing process
and the writer goes through a huge
migration going from
first week to last week oftentimes
there's months sometimes even years
between them